two journalists caught in two different
conflicts transformed unexpectedly into
war reporters one from Ethiopia the
other Ukraine when war broke out they
were faced with the task of not just
reporting while fearing for their safety
and that of their families and their
countries but with doing the job
rigorously and objectively regardless of
which side they were reporting on
works with the key of independent a few
months into Russia's war on Ukraine she
found herself investigating a new
military unit launched by President
zielinski the international Legion
I investigated Russia's war crimes
atrocities like rape and torture there
were many stories like that and then a
source came and brought this tip about
some mismanagement in the international
Legion there is a convicted criminal who
is wanted at his home country in Poland
and who is now serving in the leadership
it was
too strange to be true
so then yeah we started investigating
finding out more
physical threats with the gun sexual
harassment of female Medics this story
was among the most difficult choices in
my life because on one hand well you are
a Ukrainian right and you know that your
army is protecting you and at the same
time there are some people who are
abusing this situation and doing some
shady dealings while nobody is watching
the story made a splash and not just
because of what it exposed but because
it was such a rare example of a
Ukrainian Outlet investigating its own
military so rare in fact that Kiev
independent issued an op-ed defending
their decision to publish
people were saying that we by doing this
story were helping Russian propaganda
machine but my response to that is that
Russia can turn anything into propaganda
the purpose of John this is not sugar
coating Ukraine's realities is basically
you know showing Ukraine as it is I am
patriotic but this story
is was done out of patriotism because I
believe that shedding light on the
military is helping the military not
hurting it if there's something that we
would say is emblematic about corrupted
journalistic treatment of Wars It's
silence it's not talking about the
atrocities on our side leaving the field
open to only report on the atrocities of
the other side
it's much easier to do public relations
in effect than to really dig deep and
illuminate truth no matter how difficult
or upsetting it might be for whoever
it's something that any journalist might
struggle with whatever the conflict
wherever it may be
in 2020 a war broke out in Ethiopia
between the government led by prime
minister ABI Ahmed and the former de
facto leaders of the country the degree
in people's Liberation Front or tplf
Lucy Casa extensively covered the Civil
War a brutal conflict that claimed an
estimated 600 000 lives her first
investigation began after she received
information directly contradicting the
government's narrative
the Prime Minister was saying this is
just a law enforcement operation there
was no civilian casualty but I started
to meet people who managed to plea from
tigray and they told me the true picture
of the War I started to receive cases of
sexual violence
and killings and I was shocked to have
this information in my hands because of
the terrible human right abuses that I
never imagined
in my life I didn't really think whether
I have to report it was intuitive
cass's intuition was unusual as a member
of the minority ethnic group The
tigrainians Casa's readers would have
expected her to criticize the government
but when she started reporting war
crimes on the other side those of the
tplf she crossed the line few reporters
dared to and she paid the price she now
lives in Exile I wasn't aware of my
eternity until I started Living
in addition I believe that way helped me
to
objectively in this war otherwise I
couldn't find it very difficult hiding
the truth wouldn't help anyone So
eventually what comes out is the truth
like Osiris committed the crimes the
people who are citizens of a country or
live there they're in a real bind when
the country goes to war they're supposed
to be true to the journalistic ethos
that you seek the truth no matter where
it goes well during war there's a lot of
Reason To Fear retribution anger
retaliation that's an incentive for the
journalists frankly to
trim their sails go along with the flow
be blown with the propaganda wind of
their own government and unfortunately
journalists
usually succumb to the pressure
it's an age-old battle the idiom the
first casualty of war is truth was
coined back in 1917 specifically
referencing the constraints of War
reporters
this country is at war with Germany in
the pre-digital age censorship was much
easier governments could control the
spread of information and often deny
journalists access to the front lines
as Technologies Advance access for
journalists increased this is what the
war in Vietnam is all about it allowed
them to document and disseminate
information unlike anything seen before
often revealing the horrifying realities
of war the Marines have burned
on this old couples
Cottage yet the impact of this kind of
investigative War reporting can seem
intangible at times while shocking
details have been uncovered from
countless conflicts the revelations
often take a lot of time to shift
National attitudes or to help bring the
fighting to an end for those telling
these stories the burden of the work
with its challenges and dangers is heavy
and many are still waiting for the
reporting to make the difference it
should so there were messages that were
passed to us from military intelligence
which
basically said they disliked it
unfortunately our reporting didn't lead
to these Commander as being removed from
their positions but the situation did
change our story was published and then
stories investigating domestic issues
started appearing which I believe is is
a good sign for Ukraine and for
Ukraine's freedom of speech and
democracy it has created a huge impact
uh if it wasn't because of the
investigations we journalists did the
war might have continued I think it has
forceded the the International Community
to pressure this worrying side is into
negotiation and sign history of the
Prime Minister of which released the
statements that I am not a journalist
and and then they opened a huge online
hit campaign and uh
like physically I was attacked when I
was an artist and then I had to flee
because of this
there are moments that were vital in
reporting on War
but very few of them were turning points
because the essence of propaganda is
repetition and the exceptions are just
that they're well they're exceptional
the higher calling of Journalism
involves a deeper kind of patriotism
that your own country should be governed
by truth rather than lies or deceptions
or partial truths and as much as we
might despair about the shortage of such
reporting
fact that it exists makes the difference
between a complete
crushing of democratic possibilities and
leaving those doors open